yeah thanks dick for the very kind
introduction
yeah someone who lives kind of you know
not too far away I get the privilege of
visiting the Symons Institute pretty
frequently so it's a pleasure to be here
having an opportunity to to speak with
you and I do at the outset I do want to
thank dick and Alastair and the rest of
the leadership for just doing such a
great job for running the Institute it's
really you know over the last five years
it's added a totally new dimension to
sort of our lives this if you read a
peer scientist and very cool all right
so what I want to talk to you about
today is this thing I call
application-specific algorithm selection
so what do I mean well so let's start
with what do I mean by algorithm
selection so one of the special
semesters at the Institute this term is
on algorithms on uncertainty so there's
a lot of people here including myself
where our day job is basically
algorithms it's what we think about all
the time and you know when you do
algorithms as your day job you get used
to the following scenario you're in your
office colleague comes in sits down says
you know I was building this system you
know I was writing this software and I
realized you know I have to solve
problem X and X could be any number of
things but you see it's the Traveling
Salesman problem or something and they
sit down and they say you're an alga
this person you know which algorithm
should I use and this is actually a much
trickier question and it might seem at
first it's a little bit like you go to a
cocktail party someone introduces you to
a medical doctor and you say hey doc
I've had this 100 degree fever for the
past couple days you know what should I
do
the reason these are tricky questions in
sort of the same way is that the correct
answer depends on details which have not
been divulged so just like a 100 degree
fever could signal different kinds of
illnesses each demanding their own you
know specialized medical treatment
different collections of instances of a
common computational problem themselves
deserve their own algorithms the
algorithmic treatments that is while we
wish perhaps that computational problems
admitted some Silver Bullet algorithm
which was always the right one to use
for many of the problems that we face
is just not true the correct ink
algorithm to use really depends on the
relevant inputs so you know if you want
to just get the person out of your
office you know just like the doctor
might say you know well take two advil
and call me in the morning if it doesn't
work you know I might be tempted to say
you know try local search and call me in
the morning if it doesn't work but so
that's the key point from this slide is
just that the correct is there's a
simple point but it's fundamental for
this talk the right algorithm for
solving a problem depends on the
instances that you care about okay
here's maybe an example picture that I
just want you to have in mind you know
sort of to visualize at this point so
this is about a this is a paper by Smith
Myles at all on graph colouring I could
have picked any number of other papers
from empirical algorithm next to make
the same points so what Smith Myles did
is they scoured the literature to find
all of the sort of hard benchmarks of
graph coloring instances the people that
looked at and also they found out what
all of the state of the arts you know
heuristics were for solving graph color
and what they did is they just ran all
of these graph coloring heuristics on
all of these benchmark instances to try
to get some understanding of which
algorithm did better on which kinds of
instances so they plotted all the
instances on on a plane okay so they
figured out some way to embed graph car
instances onto the plane and using their
training data they use machine learning
to estimate a prediction function which
as a function of where you are in the
instance space predicts which of these
seven algorithms is going to be the
fastest one okay and the only thing I
want you to notice about this picture is
that all of the colors are fully
accounted for okay we have seven
different algorithms and each one has
its own sort of domain of superiority so
implicit in an analysis like this is
saying well if you want to solve graph
coloring first figure out where in this
space your typical instances lie and
then the color coding gives you a
suggestion of what kind of algorithm to
use okay so this is the the picture I
want you to have involved so what I want
to do next is I want to talk about three
examples which served to both motivate
and provide interpretations for the sort
of general theory I want to tell you
about in the second half of the talk I
just remembered I forgot to say at the
outset the meat of the talk in the
second half
that's all joint work with Rishi Gupta
who's in the back I most recently
graduated PhD student okay so three
examples all of them have connections to
the Symons Institute which I'll mention
as we go along okay so first I want to
talk about something called sad Zilla so
you may have heard that there are these
things called sap competitions is there
every other year all the people who like
to nerd out about satisfiability they
get together you get to submit any
satsang where you want and the people
who run the tournament will run your
solver on all kinds of different
instances random instances industrial
interest instances and so on and they
see which which at which solvers do the
best and they give out medals okay so
this is a thin going on for a while so a
team at University of British Columbia
including Kevin Layton Brown who's one
of the long-term visitors this semester
and the algorithm is an uncertainty
program he was also here last fall so
this UBC group had a bold even I would
say maybe slightly cheeky idea they said
you know I'll bet it would be fun to win
a sack competition but I don't really
want to write a solver that sounds like
a lot of work so they brainstormed about
how maybe they could win a competition
without actually writing a solver from
scratch and they thought about the
following idea they said well let's look
at the solvers that won a lot of medals
last time two years ago at least the
ones that are open source and they ran
those solvers on a bunch of instances
and they noticed that they had wildly
different running time performances so
some instances one algorithm would be
really fast and other one would be
really slow some other instance they'd
be flipped so you'd see a picture much
like the one on the previous slot where
different Sat solver simply did better
on different kinds of instances so the
idea was well you know let's just have a
maintainer portfolio of these Sat
solvers and when we are given a new
instance what we do is we just figure
out which of the seven Sat solvers is
most likely to run the fastest and then
we'll just run that as a black box okay
so there's no new solver except in as
much as there's this meta algorithm
picking which of these solvers to use
when confronted with a new Sat formula
okay so a little more detail so again
they had they had seven sad solvers in
their portfolio and then you know they
identified a bunch of features of sat
instances of formulas so some of the
features were kind of obvious ones like
the variable to clause ratio some of
them are not so obvious like Knuth
unbiased estimator for the search tree
size or one thing which turned out to be
super useful would was to just do local
search for like a second and see how far
you got and use that as one of your
features of a Sat instance but in any
case they define hundreds of features of
Sat formulas and then when they again
used a machine learning approach to
separately for each of the seven solvers
learn a prediction function okay so for
solver number one there was some
prediction function which when you feed
in the features of a given instance
would predict for you what their what it
thought the running time of that slot
solver would be okay so you have seven
of these prediction functions they
called them empirical performance models
EPS now once you've learned goodie PMS
for your seven solvers it's pretty clear
what your meta algorithm is you're given
an input compute the features see what
the seven EPM say and run the solver
which runs the fastest and that's
basically what they did that's basically
sad Zilla and it basically crushed the
competition in a couple competitions in
a row to the point then now actually you
know these portfolio algorithms are
explicitly disallowed in in most of
these Sat competitions all right so
that's that's the first example just
totally on the empirical side ok again
to motivate the theory I'm going to
present later so the second example
so this draws more on the connections
between computer science and economics
that dick alluded to so this is about a
really high stakes application which is
happening right now as we speak ok so
it's a auction being run by the FCC the
so-called incentive auction it started
on march 29th of this year and it's
still going now ok so that's an auction
that proceeds over a long period of time
and you know if it surprises you to hear
that the FCC is running an auction
actually they've been running auctions
for a long time since the early 90s so
whenever they wanted to sort of you know
sell some new wireless spectrum licenses
for people to you know build out new
technologies they would run an auction
so companies like the rise
or AT&T would get in an auction you know
competing for you know who gets which
licenses for the for the wireless
spectrum so that's an old idea but
there's something new which is happening
this time for the first time ever and
the reason things are different now than
they were ever before is that the really
juicy part of the spectrum is now pretty
much all accounted for it's all already
owned by somebody so if you want to
grant somebody new wireless spectrum you
have no choice but to take it away from
someone else and that's actually exactly
the point of this auction which is
running as we speak so it has two phases
it's a double auction there's a reverse
phase and a forward phase so a forward
auction that's just like when you put
something on eBay okay so when you're
selling stuff they're running a forward
auction on the other hand if you go out
for bids for contractors you know
renovate your house or whatever that's a
reverse auction that's where you're
using an auction type format to actually
purchase something so this has a reverse
phase and then a forward phase the
reverse phase the government has to
actually get some licenses take them
away from other people the other people
here are going to be television
broadcasters so that's the reverse phase
buy back licenses from people who don't
have much value for them the second
phase of the forward auction is you turn
around and you sell them back to you
know presumably telecom companies like
Verizon and so on okay so it's really
meant to transfer licenses from
broadcasters who are thought to be
driving low value from them to you know
companies that can really build out why
are the new wireless broadband
technologies you'll notice the numbers
here are pretty big so the government
was hoping to make something like twenty
plus billion dollars net profit from
this auction which is then you know
supposed to be used to reduce the
deficit and indeed this was a very you
know so to run this auction the FCC
needed congressional approval they had
to pass a bill authorizing the FCC to do
this so this is one of those rare bills
in like 2012 which actually had
bipartisan support and just passed quite
easily and it even called it the
middle-class tax relief and Job Creation
Act
I mean who's gonna vote against that
right okay so that's the high-level idea
and again the forward auction has been
around for close to 25 years the reverse
auction is totally new so let me drill
down a little bit more on the reverse
auction okay so the format for the
reverse auction was proposed by two
economist colleagues of mine at Stanford
Paul Milgram and Ilya Segal we had Paul
Milgram at the Institute several times
last year last fall when we had a
special program on economics and
computation he actually gave an open
lecture in this room kind of almost
exactly a year ago on exactly this topic
on the incentive option so they proposed
how to do it and this is the one that
got adopted and what's really cool is
all right so what you know fundamentally
what problem does the reverse auction
have to solve it has to figure out which
of the television stations stay on the
air and which ones get kicked off the
air that's what you're trying to figure
out and the Milgram Segal format really
says you know do whatever you want as
long as you use a greedy algorithm now
why we're two economists caring about
greedy algorithms is because they turn
out to have really nice economic
properties so it turns out if you use a
greedy algorithm to solve the underlying
computational problem it admits sort of
a very nice implementation what's called
a descendant clock implementation which
is really kind of a pleasure to
participate it okay so it's very easy
for the participants so that's why they
focused on greedy algorithms so what
kind of greedy algorithm should be used
and again don't forget the problem we
have all these television stations
they're currently on the air we want to
leave a some you know small subset of
them on the air and by everyone else out
okay kick everyone else out the air so
it's a greedy algorithm for picking who
stays on the air all right so greedy
algorithms you all know how they work
you usually do a one pass over the
objects you know according to some
ranking and then you make an irreparable
decision each time you consider an
object about whether they're included or
excluded so what order should one
consider the stations in well so the
first thing on the good side so stations
with higher value for their license that
is less willingness to accept a certain
offer so stations with high value for
their license should be prioritized for
staying on the air all right that just
makes sense the people who wanted more
should be
you know toward the front of the line of
being on the year so that you could just
consider the value that would be a
totally reasonable greedy algorithm but
there's at least one other thing which
might be worth considering which has to
do with television stations conflicting
with each other so as you can imagine if
you have two different television
stations and they're broadcasting areas
overlap they can't both broadcast on the
same channel okay then you get sort of
bad interference and a significant part
of both of their neighborhoods
so anyone you conflict with ie your
broadcasting region overlaps with they
cannot be on the same channel as you
okay so what does that mean that means
actually you know if some station
conflicts with lots of other people you
may be less inclined to keep them on the
air because they impose so many other
constraints on who else you could keep
on the air so more conflicts is bad so
you could also discriminate against teal
with television stations who overlap
with lots of other neighboring stations
so those are the two criteria they
decided to focus on in the greedy
algorithm which actually got implemented
and and you know so given two criteria
like this there's many ways to combine
them into a scoring rule the scoring
rule which was implemented is you know
to first order this one okay so it's so
you know higher rank is better so the
greedy this is the greedy score with
higher numbers being better for the
station so it's linearly increasing and
the value of that station and then it
decreases with the inverse square root
of the number of conflicts so this is
literally the formula that's you know in
the option being run right now it's not
just made up people definitely argued
about this one half quite a bit like
what's up with this exponent does this
make any sense doesn't it seem kind of
weird there is some theoretical
precursors to this square root rule
specifically a paper by Lehmann
O'Callahan and show them on comma tour
of options where they're basically using
a similar greedy algorithm in a slightly
different context my understanding is
that the reason Milgram and Segal
proposed this rule is because they tried
lots of rules like this in particular
they tried lots of different exponents
and on synthetic data that they deemed
representative exponents pretty close to
0.5 seemed to be the sweet spot okay so
that was as my understanding the primary
consideration for why the
settled on this exponent of 1/2
experiments with synthetic data ok so
this activity of figuring out you know
what should that exponent be and why 1/2
and doing it from data I mean this
should remind you of something that you
know at least if your machine learning
friends are like my machine learning
friends something that you know some of
your friends are doing all day long
every single day namely parameter tuning
or if you like hyper parameter
optimization so this has many forms so
I'm just pointing out an analogy so you
know what we just did is basically a
parameter tuning problem of which there
are many more across computer science so
these days you hear mostly about machine
learning even just gradient descent
something as simple as gradient descent
you got to choose a step size and it's
kind of a dark art how you choose the
right step size then you do it by trial
and error for the most part this can get
even hairier with hyper parameters like
if you're doing regular eyes regression
you have to figure out you know what's
the coefficient for the regularization
term again typically you know you use
trial and error kind of heuristics for
figuring that out okay you know
parameter optimization is certainly not
unique to machine learning so one
example I like is C flex so C flex is a
well-known commercial solver for linear
programs and integer programs and you
know maybe at first you'd like a linear
programming algorithm we think of it as
some fixed algorithm oh it's just
simplex or whatever actually simplex is
really a meta algorithm parameterised by
many many parameters 135 parameters in
fact ok so for any instantiation of
those parameters you get n algorithm but
SEAPLEX itself is this family over all
possible parameter choices so there's a
221 page reference manual sort of a
guide to these parameters and if you're
thinking wow if 200 plus pages there
must be some really sage advice about
how I should think about the parameters
think again pretty much all they have to
say is you may need to experiment
thanks c-plus ok so I mentioned this
slide because you know these types of
parameter tunings there's also something
I kind of have in the back of my mind
once we get to the theoretical
development a little
later okay all right
so the last example I wanted to give
this is now sort of on the purely
theoretical side I think you could
implement what's in these papers but I
don't think they have been implemented
so this is a sort of small but very nice
literature on self improving algorithms
and the you know the person who's been
really the consistent contributor and
self improving algorithms is Chad Reed
he's also a long-term participant in the
algorithms and uncertainty semester this
term so what is it so what's the model
so the model is consider a problem like
sorting okay so you're gonna see
instances of the problem so like a raise
to sort in a sequence and they're not
going to be adversely chosen they're
going to be drawn from some distribution
which you are not privy to okay so the
first array you see you have no idea
what it's coming from you just want to
use merge short whatever but then you
start seeing more and more arrays and
it's conceivable you'd notice patterns
in the kinds of instances that you're
seeing now you know when you're sorting
you could always just use say merge
short and be n log N worst case time but
actually if you assume something about
the distribution of the inputs there's
many cases where you can beat n log n
time and do you even get sort of
expected linear time okay so if you're
in one of these lucky cases where the
data has the structure that you can be
merge sort you'd like to recognize that
automatically and ideally sort as
quickly as the information theoretic
optimal algorithm for the distribution
okay and so the focus in these papers is
mostly on just making sure you don't use
too much bookkeeping so it'll be a
little bit different from our focus but
still this is very much going to be in
the spirit of the theory I'm going to
tell you about today okay self-improving
out with okay so those are the those are
the three examples I wanted to cover of
you know how it might remember where we
were what what is the algorithm
selection and we sort of looked around
and look for some case studies how do
people actually do algorithm selection
and so we saw sat Zilla
which is this idea that you choose an
algorithm from a portfolio on the fly as
a function of the instance features we
saw the FCC auction example which is
basically kind of a parameter tuning
problem figuring out what should be the
right exponent and then we noticed
there's lots of other parameter tuning
problems in the world also and then this
third one of self improving algorithm
we're inputs are coming in from a
distribution and you want to do almost
as well as if you knew the distribution
okay so those are the three examples we
saw and so now you know and so I've been
you know a big fan of all of these works
for a long time and for many years I was
wondering you know what would you know
appropriate theory look like to help one
think about what's happening in this way
of using algorithms these types of
algorithm applications so this talk is
sort of the best answer I've come up
with to date you know about what is the
theory which most closely mirrors these
types of case studies so what's going to
look like what should a theory look like
well I guess the first thing I want to
point out is it's not going to look like
the way analysis is usually done in the
theoretical analysis of algorithms so
usually in theoretical analysis we look
at worst-case analysis and I'm going to
argue that that's inappropriate for what
we're trying to capture here so what do
I mean by worst-case analysis so you're
trying to basically summarize a very
complicated object which is the
performance profile of an algorithm
right so notice when you say the
performance of an algorithm this is
actually kind of a complex object right
so it's really a vector in effect of say
the running time or the solution quality
of this algorithm on every possible
input you might ever run it on ok that's
sort of in its you know grandly the the
performance of an algorithm
now the reason about algorithms you
usually want some kind of summary
statistic you're like let me just think
about you know sort of one number so
that I can compare algorithms in a clean
way and worst-case analysis just says
use the summary statistic of the worst
the algorithm ever does in any input
possibly parameterize by the input size
something like that okay now worst-case
analysis has served the study of
algorithms very very well when I teach
undergraduate algorithms pretty much
everything I do in the class is worst
case analysis and so let's review you
know what do I tell the undergrads why
are we doing it well so you know first
of all the best case scenario is kind of
utopia right when you can prove a
positive result that's that it's true
even in the worst case you basically can
put the problem to rest okay you
basically never think again about how to
solve it whatever the input is you don't
care you have a guarantee that you're
happy with
secondly despite the fact that such a
strong positive guarantee there are tons
of killer applications
so specifically undergraduate algorithms
is basically a parade of killer
applications of worst-case analysis but
I'm thinking like you know Dijkstra's
algorithm implemented with heaps or
something like this okay there's a
super-fast theoretical running time it's
also a super practical algorithm that
you'd really want to use okay but
there's also some well-known drawbacks
to worst-case analysis so let me just
remind you of these so obviously if it's
going to be incorrect if it's going to
give you bad advice it's going to stem
from the fact that it's too pessimistic
okay that this could be governed by
performance on inputs which will never
show up okay and that can actually lead
to flat-out bad advice from worst case
analysis so perhaps the most famous
example is linear programming and the
simplex method so theoretically in the
worst case the simplex method requires
an exponential number of iterations to
compute an optimal solution but it's
it's new it's almost impossible to find
instances where you see anything like
that the typical performance of the
simplex method in practice is much
closer to linear in the input size
forget about exponential so in effect
worst case analysis is telling you don't
use the simplex method use some other
method which you know has a polynomial
time worst case guarantee but that's
really just not very good advice and so
in practice you actually do want to use
simplex most of the time so that's a
problem I've stated the fact that there
is no data model as a pro of worst-case
analysis right so when you have positive
results you're happy you never made any
assumptions about the data but you can
also think about that being its Achilles
heel okay so there's no data model in
worst-case analysis or if there is a
data model it's the Murphy's Law data
model it's a Murphy's Law says whatever
goes wrong will go wrong
worst-case analysis says whatever
algorithm you pick the worst input for
that algorithm is the one that's going
to show up is the one that's the most
relevant okay so the input that you care
about actually depends on the algorithm
that you use which you know outside of
maybe some cryptographic applications I
claim is just sort of a paranoid and
incoherent way to think about the world
okay all right so we want to get away
from worst-case analysis again remember
our thesis at the beginning the right
algorithm to use depends on the
instances that you care about the
relevant inputs so we need some notion
of relevant inputs that means we're
going to have to have some kind of at
least you know weak data model all right
so it's not going to look like
traditional worst-case analysis of
algorithms but it will resemble you know
a different part of theory which is very
well understood which is learning theory
so the proposal is going to be to think
about application-specific algorithm
selection as a learning problem so
normally in learning you think about
things like prediction functions or
classification you know so maybe you
think about things like half-spaces or
decision trees so here instead of half
spaces or decision trees we're gonna be
thinking about algorithms so algorithms
will correspond to what are normally
called hypotheses or concepts on the
learning theory side in learning theory
usually think about a loss function you
know which says as a function of what
the correct answer is and what your
guess was how costly what penalty do you
suffer the analog of the loss function
here is just going to be the algorithm
performance like say the running time
and what I'm going to try to convince
you is that you know two of the dominant
paradigms in learning theory both the
kind of offline or batch learning model
in addition to the online or regret
minimization model very naturally model
this problem of algorithm specific
application specific algorithm selection
okay so that's the plan for the for the
rest of the top any questions if you'd
interrupt whenever you want of course
all right so let me actually tell you a
little bit about the formalism and the
types of things one can prove in this
formalism so I'm going to talk mostly
about the offline or batch model so let
me tell you what I mean by that so first
of all in the very first line we're
gonna see a departure from the usual way
you think about algorithms in worst-case
analysis so the first ingredient to the
model is a set of algorithms what do I
have in mind for example could be a set
of seven Sat solvers 4/7 graph coloring
heuristics or it could be you know a
greedy heuristic all greedy heuristics
for that auction problem for some
exponent probably possibly different
than one half okay so that's what I have
in mind by a class of algorithms so you
have committed up front to use one of
these algorithms but you haven't
committed to which one and again
remember our tenant the whole point here
is that the right algorithm to use
should depend on the instances that's
why we're not we're at no point will we
advocate a single algorithm until we
until we specify the data model okay so
like I said we need some and in that
analog to a loss function so I'm just
going to note denote this by cost so a
here is an algorithm Z here is an inputs
and this is whatever performance measure
we've decided to care about so this
could be for example the running time of
a on Z maybe it's an np-hard problem and
this is a heuristic then that could be
the quality of the solution output by a
on Z or its approximation ratio and so
on okay so have a performance measure
I'm going to assume it's bounded between
0 and capital H capital H is how big
this performance measure can get so for
example the maximum running time before
you just go ahead and time out what
we're going to want to do is think about
algorithms as a real valued function so
what's the domain what's the range so
the domain is just the input okay so
think of that we've fixed a
computational problem we fixed an
algorithm for that computational problem
now we can think of the mapping from
inputs to that of that computational
problem to the performance of this
algorithm a on this input
okay so we think of algorithms as real
valued functions mapping inputs to
performance I know that probably sounds
a little abstract so let me let me make
it much more concrete and sort of tell
you about a specific family of
algorithms which I'm going to use as a
running example for the rest of the talk
most of the results are more general but
this is a very good one to just keep in
mind so think about the independent set
problem and so on the independent set
problem you have a graph an independent
set is a subset of the vertices so that
no two vertices are adjacent
okay so adjacent vertices are disallowed
in an independent set vertices also have
weights that's what these labels mean so
these are the weights of the vertices in
this problem the goal is to compute the
independent set with the maximum total
weight it's a well-known np-hard problem
that we're going to look at greedy
heuristics for this np-hard problem
maybe the first greedy algorithm you
think about would just feel like okay
well you know we want a large weight
independent set so let's just start with
the biggest weight vertex let's go ahead
and greedily put that in our independent
set given that we've done that we can't
put any of these three vertices in our
independent set so in the next step of
the greedy algorithm we just take the
only other vertex we can the two okay
for a total of six that's not the only
greedy algorithm you could use another
one that you see a lot in the literature
is weight divided by one plus the degree
of a vertex why well this is sort of
like a bang per buck ratio when you
remove a vertex V when you put that in
the independent set you're also
excluding from future consideration all
of its neighbors its degree of V
neighbors so you've basically ripped out
of the graph one plus degree of V
vertices and you earned WV units in your
objective function so this is the bang
per buck per vertex removed so it's an
that that's another natural thing to
maximize now in this particular graph
the algorithm does something different
it actually computes an optimal solution
so in this case because this is a high
weight and only has degree one that's
going to get picked first the other
isolated node will get picked seconds
now this is blocked and this is
this is not blocked so it concludes with
this vertex okay so we changed the
greedy rule and we saw we got a
different answer in this case the second
algorithm was optimal it would be very
easy to come up with examples where this
algorithm is suboptimal
and the first algorithm would be optimal
okay so which algorithm is better just
really depends on the graph that you're
looking at you might have you might see
a resemblance between weighted
independent set and the auction example
that we were talking about earlier
remember then we were talking about you
know basically keeping stations on that
air and stations could interfere with
each other so there's a clear
abstraction here where you know
basically vertices correspond to
stations and edges correspond to
conflicts so this is the same kind of
problem that was being studied in that
in the auction problem and you can also
imagine a square root rule here as well
okay and again a priori there is no
reason to think you know there's no
reason to know why one of these
particular greedy algorithms would be
better for your application than another
one okay so what so what's an example of
a class of algorithms well let's just
you know here's like the first thing we
could try and again the results will be
much more general but just think about
this class suppose we just interpolate
between the two greedy algorithms I just
showed you the one that orders by value
on them on the orders by value over 1
plus degree so one way to interpolate is
we'll look at only greedy algorithms
that use the ratio between the weights
and 1 plus the degree raised to some
power ok where P is going to be 0 could
be 1 that recovers the two examples so
far it could be 1/2 that's in the spirit
of the auction solution or anything else
ok so for each choice of P we have one
greedy algorithm varying over all
choices of P we have an infinite set of
greedy algorithms
so I hope you have a better feel for
what I mean by a class of algorithms at
this point so let me tell you about the
the rest of the model okay and if you're
familiar with PAC learning it's
basically the same as a PAC learning
model so also in the spirit of the self
improving algorithms discussion we will
commit to the fact that inputs are drawn
from a distribution okay so this is a
departure from worst case analysis
before you've chosen an algorithm I've
committed to a distribution over inputs
so that's sort of a coherent way of
thinking about which inputs you care
about all right so call that F that
distribution now the algorithm designer
will not be pretty directly to this
input distribution that would be too
easy and maybe too unrealistic rather
the algorithm designer has benchmark
instances benchmark datasets which we
interprets as iid samples from this
unknown distribution over inputs so
knowing the distribution only in as much
as you know as samples from the
distribution your job is then to commit
to an algorithm from this class like a
value of P that you will then use
forevermore on instances that are also
drawn iid from the same distribution F
okay so it's called batch learning
because I give you all of these s
samples at once in a batch you process
them as long as you want as a function
only of the sample as you figure out
which algorithm from your class you're
going to run on future instances okay
you may be tempted to sort of you know
if you remember the sad Zilla example at
the beginning you may be tempted to
remember well you know didn't we have
that example where we were more
ambitious and actually we didn't just
commit once and for all to an algorithm
forevermore rather we had a mapping from
input features to algorithms that that's
just fine in the same formalism right so
you can optimize over mappings from
instance features to algorithms rather
than just optimizing over algorithms as
well okay all right so what's the
benchmark how so you know what does it
mean that you solve this problem well
you know given that you're restricting
to an algorithm from C the best thing
you can do is do as well as the best
algorithm in this class
okay so the goal is to find some
algorithm in the class
ideally a star that's approximately
optimizes the expected performance where
this expectation is with respect to the
input distribution which of course you
don't know okay so that's the goal in
The Bachelor new model exactly
so what might me hope to prove well we
could look to just classical learning
theory again this is a totally you know
standard set up and say you know what
what kind of you know nice rules of
thumb are there on the learning theory
side and something you learn you know in
Chapter two if not chapter one is that
the sample complexity so the data
requirements needed to learn a good
classification rule or a good prediction
function scales with how complex the set
of prediction functions or
classification rules you're looking at
and so the more complex set of
hypotheses you're willing to consider
the more data is required so we you know
so for those of you know the VC
dimension this is the kind of thing I'm
talking about and as a corollary of this
you get on the learning theory side that
as long as you're only interested in
learning the best simple function for
the best simple classifier the data
requirements are quite modest so what we
might hope for algorithm selection would
be an analogous rule saying as long as
your class of algorithms involves only
simple algorithms whatever that means
then you should be able to learn over
that family from a modest amount of data
that's the kind of theorems are going to
be aspiring toward so to do that we need
to commit to what we mean by a class of
algorithms being simple or not simple
okay so the good news is is we do not
need a new definition for this purpose
we can just use sort of off-the-shelf or
classical definition from statistical
learning theory which is known as the
suitor dimension I will give you a
definition of the suitor dimension that
I'm not going to do it for a couple
slides okay put a couple of slides I
want to tell you why maybe you should
care about seeing the definition of the
suitor dimension okay but so this is
what's going to work for us so what do
we want from this definition well what
do you want from any definition right on
the one hand right to convince you that
a definition is interesting I should
convince you first of all that there's
interesting implications if you meet the
definition so we're gonna see that we're
gonna see that if you meet the
definition then you have low sample
complexity for learning the best
algorithm from a class secondly you
better have some juicy examples examples
you care about that actually meet the
definition so
then we'll talk about four families of
algorithms like greedy algorithms what
actually is the pseudo donation okay all
right so first the implications so
suppose I tell you that a family of
algorithms has low pseudo dimension is
simple in that sense what does that buy
you well then you immediately know that
the sample complexity is reasonable
specifically what I want you to focus on
so this is the sample complexity here
what I want you to focus is on is on the
linear dependence on D okay so the
suitor dimension whatever it is it's
governing the sample complexity okay so
if D is small this is the sample
capacity is gonna be small if d is big
the sample complexity is going to be big
okay what are the other parameters so H
you might recall I was assuming that
performance values range between 0 and H
so that's sort of the spread of possible
values we're thinking about an epsilon
is the additive error you're willing to
tolerate okay so the goal really is to
just output an algorithm whose expected
performance is within epsilon of the
best algorithm of your class okay so it
shouldn't be surprising to see some
dependence on this ratio H over epsilon
the spread over the error required and
the interesting part is the linear
dependence on D ok so that's so the
guarantees this is what the guarantee
says if your class of algorithms has
suited dimension D and you have this
many samples then that's enough samples
to learn the best algorithm from that
class how do you do it well if nothing
else you can just use brute force search
okay you can look for smarter algorithms
but if nothing else here's how you use
brute force search you have your samples
you just see which of your algorithms
does the best on your samples and then
you just use that for evermore and the
guarantee is that the algorithm that you
choose which was optimized for the data
will be within epsilon epsilon of the
best algorithm from that class okay so
yeah high level points suitor dimension
if it's low whatever it means if it's
low sample complexity is also low
all right so you know so far that's
totally classic stuff so now the
question is are there any interesting
examples of this dimension of the pseudo
dimension being low so for example
greedy algorithms what can you say about
the pseudo dimension well I haven't told
you the definition so wouldn't be fair
to ask you but even if you knew the
definition it's not totally clear a
priori in fact I still remember you know
a couple times I was told a couple
friends of mine that you know I was busy
computing you know effectively the VC
dimension of greedy algorithms and they
looked at me like I had lost my mind you
can tell this did not type check like VC
dimension greedy algorithms what are you
talking about but it makes sense and you
get nice results ok so so just a sanity
check
so for finite sets that's not a very
interesting case so just by elementary
arguments you get a suit of dimension of
log of the size so whenever you just
have like seven algorithms or something
you know this is a very low sample
requirement much more interesting and
what I'll focus on is greedy algorithms
ok so they're going to be greedy
algorithms with one parameter like the
examples I've shown you thus far and the
pseudo dimension is only logarithmic in
N where n here is the size of the
instances that you're getting from the
distribution so for example an
independent set and would be the number
of vertices in the graph so the suitor
dimension is only logarithmic in the
input size which again as we saw means
the sample complexity will also be only
logarithmic in the input size and it's
definitely not just it so you know not
all classes of algorithms have low
suitor dimension I mean it does
differentiate so sufficiently
complicated classes of algorithms can
have unbounded pseudo dimension but this
is robust in the sense that lots of
other types of algorithms also have low
suitor dimensions so if you do local
search you get some kind of dependence
on log of the neighborhood size but
otherwise login in the self-improving
sorting work that I mentioned they in
effect identify a sub collection of
sorting algorithms which are always
guaranteed to be near optimal which has
pseudo dimension basically linear in the
input size and if you want to do this at
Zillah application where you more
generally learn the best mapping from
input features to algorithms then you
just suffer a linear depend
on the number of features that you're
using okay so the sample complexity
remains small for these as long as each
algorithm itself has small suitor
dimension okay all right so those are
the two things that I wanted to promise
you first of all if you meet the
definition automatically get cool
consequences secondly actually these
motivating examples do satisfy the
definition alright so yeah because this
you know plays a starring role in these
results let me actually tell you the
definition although if the slide doesn't
make sense don't worry about it that you
won't you won't need this again so for
those of you that know vc-dimension it's
really just the real-valued analog right
so so why is VC dimension not quite what
we're looking for so VC dimension is a
measure of complexity of binary
functions zero one functions we have
real valued functions okay how do you
turn a real valued function into a
binary function you just threshold it is
it above or below a given threshold
that's literally it
that's the suitor dimension so there's
still a notion of a set being shattered
meaning you exhibit all possible
different you know labelings of that
sets the only trick is now you get to
pick whatever thresholds you want okay
so the shatter is set s you picked your
favorite set of thresholds one for each
point in the set and it should be the
case that for every subset of the
shattering you can find a function which
is above the thresholds on the
prescribed set and below the thresholds
outside the prescribed set okay so
really you're just saying you want all
possible different behaviors to arise as
you range over all of the algorithms in
your class okay and then the pseudo
dimension is just the biggest set size
that you can shatter now if this seems
like a mouthful that's fine I mean the
first time you've seen it it is a
mouthful for sure so the one thing I
want you to take away from this is
despite the fact there's a lot of words
it's actually really not very hard to
prove bounds good bounds on the pseudo
dimension for things we care about so
let me prove this point by just giving
you a sketch for the for our running
example so let's imagine so this is it
extends to sort of general greedy
algorithms but let's just focus on those
weighted independent set greedy
algorithms we were looking at
for okay so remember this algorithm
Iliev algorithms parameterised by P this
is specifying how you trade off the wave
with a degree okay so the claim is that
the suitor dimension of this family of
algorithms is only logarithmic in the
number of vertices okay what does that
mean that means we can only shatter
subsets up to size log in okay we can't
shatter anything bigger that's what it
means to have log n pseudo dimension
so let's see why that's true so fix a
set of inputs right so this contains s
things each one is a graph with weights
on it okay so we have s graphs with
weights now there's an infinite number
of algorithms but you're not going to
see an infinite number of distinct
executions on this finite set of samples
okay so call two choices of the exponent
P and Q equivalent if on literally every
input in this sample the algorithms run
and lockstep identically meaning they
all they pick exactly they consider the
vertices in exactly the same order okay
so that's what it means for two
different choices of an exponent to be
equivalent with respect to the sample so
if I don't fix the sample up front if I
just pick two exponents I can always
find an instance that weighted an
independent set where they do different
things but if you fix the sample first
then often nearby P's and Q's will have
exactly the same execution on all of the
inputs in that sample okay so the lemma
that we need is that the number of
equivalence classes can only grow
polynomial e with the size of the
instances N and the number of samples
little s why is that enough well
remember the definition of shattering
says you need to exhibit two to the S
different behaviors okay to get all two
to the S different possible labelings
so if you really only have you know poly
and n and acid distinct algorithms at
your disposal you can only get this many
different behaviors for s up to log n
okay so the theorem reduces to this
lemma here number of equivalence classes
only grows polynomial with N and s so
let me just give you the idea for this
so fix your pics the sample size again
has size s
how do we use it it's a greedy algorithm
so here's how we use it
the greedy algorithms execution depends
only on how various comparisons get
resolved over the course of the
algorithm so one of these greedy
algorithms for the weighted independent
set problem what is it going to do it's
going to compare you know the weights
over the degree to some power to the
weight over the degree to some power
between two different vertices vnx okay
maybe V wins maybe X wins
okay who knows but the point is if you
tell me the results of all comparisons
of this form I know exactly what your
algorithm is going to do okay so the
results of the comparisons fix the
entire trajectory of the greedy
algorithm so that's an important point
the second thing we use so where's the
single parameter property so this is
where we use the greedy algorithm where
do we use the single parameter property
well the claim is that for a given
potential comparison like say the vertex
V versus the vertex X as you range over
all algorithms ie as you range over
values of P let's say starting from zero
and going to infinity the result of this
comparison will flip at most once as you
start P at zero and go all the way out
to infinity okay so it may be that when
P is zero you know this thing has a
bigger weight so maybe this is bigger
than this when P is zero that's going to
remain true for a while but then it's
some value of P you know who knows three
whatever it's going to flip the other
way and this side will be bigger than
this side but then the claim is for all
larger P this side will continue to be
bigger so you have one interval where
this is the winner of the comparison and
a second interval where this is the
winner of the comparison so for a fixed
possible comparison there's exactly one
threshold exponent where the result of
that comparison switches now there
aren't that many relevant comparisons
right so the number of relevant
comparisons you just have one for each
pair of vertices and each possible
degree that they might have and that's a
polynomial and an S number of
comparisons you need to care about and
you know so that says if the number of
comparisons is only this it says there's
only a polynomial number of thresholds
okay so values of P where the X
tuition of the greedy algorithm differs
at P minus epsilon versus P plus epsilon
that only happens a polynomial number of
times so you only have a polynomial
number of different equivalence classes
okay all right
so just quick summary from the from the
batch model so again there's a suitor
dimension definition if you don't
remember the definition but remember
that it's not that hard to bound it lots
of algorithm classes we care about it's
small and it automatically gives you
sample complexity results also I'm not
really talking much about running time
and indeed that's largely an open
question but you can implement these
learning algorithms at least in time
only exponential in the pseudo dimension
so when the suitor dimension is this
small you actually get a polynomial time
algorithm for learning the best
algorithm from data also okay
so let me just do two more slides and
then I'll wrap up so after we talked
about the auction problem and sort of
trying to choose that 1/2 exponent we
mentioned that we can think of that as
just sort of a version of parameter
tuning which is being done all over the
place especially in machine learning so
I just want to mention one result that
we have which you know it's it's sort of
a baby step but I hope it's a teaser I
hope it you know motivates more general
results about hyper parameter
optimization so the so this this results
about gradient descent choosing
parameters and gradient descent and
there's actually three things you might
need to choose in gradient descent where
do you start
what is your stopping criterion what air
are you willing to tolerate but most
interestingly third the step size so how
far do you go in the direction of the
gradient in each step so that's what
people really worry about the most so
suppose you look up you know a textbook
on convex optimization what does it tell
you about choosing the step size does it
give you an against well it does so for
example if you have a strongly convex
function basically the textbook will
tell you it'll say as long as your step
size is below this threshold so as long
as your step size is sufficiently small
you're guaranteed determinate and some
number of iterations close to the global
minimum and it gives you the formula as
a function of how strongly convex it is
of exactly you know what's this
threshold on the step size but you know
in practice this is super conservative
right so this is the step size which
actually gets you the theoretical
guarantee in practice you almost always
use a much bigger step size you run the
risk of overshooting but typically
you'll get there in much fewer
iterations okay so the goal here was to
so what we had in mind was someone
trying to understand the death step size
in this convex regime where there are
being overly aggressive with the step
size and again you can prove similar
kinds of sample complexity results so
now we're thinking about a distribution
really over convex functions and
starting points and you're trying to
figure out the step size which minimizes
the expected number of iterations before
convergence and that again can be
analyzed using slightly different
techniques but you know it's still very
tractable analysis okay so I don't have
time for the online model let me just
say what it is so I told you about the
batch model which is the two
characteristics of the bat's model are
there's an unknown distribution and I
give you a whole bunch of samples at
once from that unknown distribution the
online model differs in two respects the
first is that its distribution free its
prior free so it actually has a
worst-case flavor to it an adversary
will pick for you a for example weighted
graph at each time step the second
difference as would suggest its online
meaning I don't give you a whole bunch
of samples as a batch upfront rather I
unveil to you inputs one by one and each
on each day you have to decide on an
algorithm before seeing the input on
that day the goal then is to figure out
the right algorithm to use or the right
parameter settings which is almost as
good as the best algorithm or best
parameter settings in hindsight okay so
you can also get results in the online
model Rishi is actually giving a talk on
exactly this on the details of the
online model at the next workshop and
the algorithm is an uncertainty semester
which is the third week of November so
for those of you get around I definitely
urge you to check it out because I think
really proof some quite cool things
about this model
so let me just wrap up with a couple
open questions so as I said you know I
really have not addressed computational
complexity issues this was all just
about information theoretic results
sample complexity bounds how much data
at least in principle is necessary to
identify the best algorithm from a class
we you know we've been thinking about
this we've been thinking about
non-trivial learning algorithms it seems
like a worthy challenge problem so it
would be great to have some examples
where you can beat brute-force search I
think there must be at least some
isolated examples out there I suspect
there's a fair amount of work to do
doing complexity theories saying you
can't beat brute force search for a lot
of these learning type problems under
suitable complexity assumptions so I
think there's a lot of work to do there
as I mentioned you know I offer you this
gradient descent result just as kind of
a proof of concepts that I think you
really can reason about parameter tuning
on in a machine learning context I see
no reason why you couldn't have more
general results of this form and then
finally you know I propose for you a
sort of a non-standard way to measure
the simplicity of a class of algorithms
say something which you know usually we
would leave undefined in a text book or
a research paper so the suitor dimension
provides you with some notion of how
simple the classes of course we have a
lot of other measures of the complexity
of algorithms and problems and I can't
help but wonder if there's any
non-trivial connections between these
different ways of measuring complexity
so I'll leave it there thanks very much